انتظروا حلقتين
[موسيقى]
للمكفوفين صار لي بالمجال تقريبا خمس
سنوات
هي مو لغه لانها مو شيء يعني خاص فينا
خلاص هذه دوخه يعني مثلا نتكلم فيها ونقرا
فيها ونتحدث فيها لا هي طريقه تعيننا في
القراءه او الكتابه سواء ايش كانت اللغه
سواء كانت لغه عربيه لغه انجليزيه لغه
فرنسيه هنديه الى اخره طريقه اخترعها كفيف
فرنسي هو فقط تمام لكن تبارك الرحمن يعني
هو كان ذكي متفوق فاكمل دراسته وكده فصار
اصلا يعني بعد معلم في المعهد الملكي
فرنسا وسبحان الله دائما يعني انا احس قصه
لويس
على المستوى الشخصي كون انه الشخص اذا فقد
شيء يعطي اشياء اخرى
ما كان احد بالعالي يعني يعرفها لكن
الوالده الله يجزاها عني الف خير يعني
حاولت كثر ما تقدر تتعلمها عشان تعلمني
اياها بالنسبه للوالده يعني لما تحكي لي
يعني لما كبرت وكذا تقول انه ترى كانت مره
صعبه مره صعبه علي لاني انا ما استخدمها
بحياتي ابدا الا معك
[موسيقى]
لانه اول شيء اتاكد انه الشخص اللي يبغى
يتعلم ابراهيم انه لمس عندك كويس لانه
طريقه برايل تعتمد على اللمس اذا انا
اللمس عندي مشكله خلاص انا ما اقدر يصير
عندي خلل بالقراءه يصير عندي ضعف ويصير
عندي عدم تركيز وعدم متفرقه بين الحروف
[موسيقى]
ما اقول لك ادرسك الف باء تاء ثاء جيم كده
يعني تسلسلي لا اجمل الحروف المتشابهه مع
بعض يعني الف هي النقطه الاولى الباء
الاولى والثانيه اللام اولى ثانيه ثالثه
من الالف نقطه الباء نقطتين اللام ثلاث
نقاط فنجمع الحروف المتشابهه ونبدا
حاولت اتعلم طريق العاديه كثير وعرفت انه
الله كبيره يعني انت مثل الالف عندكم خط
ما ادري اذا انا صح ولا لا احنا الان
احنا نقطتين تحت بعض انتم لا يعني زي كذا
بدا في نقطه تحت في اختلافات كثيره اتذكر
يعني كنت اجيب يعني مثلا صلصال
ما ادري ما احس اني استوعبت بعدين جربت
هذه الطريقه اللي اجيب يعني اشياء بارزه
والمس اشياء بديت افهم بس عرفت انه في
كمان شيء انه انتم لما الحروف بتصير يعني
كيف بقول لك الكلب بالكلمه طيب الحروف
تختلف مثلا تختلف وسط الكلمه تختلف في
نهايه الكلمه تختلف اول الكلمه صار عندي
لي يا الله احنا مره سهل كتابتها انت مره
صعبه كتابتكم
[موسيقى]
اعتقد النبراير شيء مهم يكفي اني يعني اهم
شيء اهم شيء اني اقدر اكرهها قران
الكريم احنا
تسمعونا في ناس ما شاء الله حافظينها في
ناس كده بس التلاوه
يلا خلاص راح نستغني عن طريقه برايل على
السمع
واذا اعتمدوا على السمع يعني راح يضطروا
للناس دائما
واحده من البنات يعني كنت مشرفه عليها
باختبار الاسبوع الماضي كانت تقول واحنا
جالسين هي طبعا عندها ضعف نظر يعني فكانت
تقول لا تيتشر سميره قلت لها نعم قالت لي
اتمنى اعطيك واحده من عيوني قلت انا ليش
قلت عشان يصير شوفك اقوى ويعني من كثر
الحنياتها كنا لما نمشي مثلا بنروح
الكلاسي المخصصه
انا بكون قدامك
[موسيقى]
انا استخدم منتجات ابل منتجات ابل سواء
كان ايفون ايباد
كل كل الاجهزه
تحتوي على
امكانيه الوصول للمكفوفين او ذوي الاعاقه
فمن ضمنها شيء اسماء فويس اوفر هذا يعتبر
قارئ شاشه اي شيء اضغط على الشاشه يقرا لي
اياه واي شيء اكتبه يقرا لي اياه عندي ترى
اللون
[موسيقى]
تضرب
حلقتي
حطيت ستارز
[موسيقى]
في عصر رقمي متغير باستمرار المواكبه هي
اساس النجاح ولاننا رواد المستقبل الرقمي
نوظف خبراتنا وقدراتنا لنمكن نبتكر نبدع
في تبني احدث التقنيات وتوفير الحلول
بكفاءه وذكاء سلوج السيسي
[موسيقى]
رغم انه هو صاحب الشعب احيانا
يحسونك انت غير قادره
يعني مثلا انهم يشوفونك انت ما شاء الله
انجزتي وكذا والى اخرها بس في مواطن معينه
يقول لا ما تقدرين او كذا طيب اعطوني فرصه
انا مرهقدر الاماكن السلالم يعني اللي
فيها طريقه برايل انا جدا اقدرها جدا
احتفل فيها واحتفل وحتى يعني اهالي
ينبسطون دائما لما نروح مكان طريقه
تفكر فيك
[موسيقى]